are you having trouble losing some extra
weight is your regular routine of diet
and exercise not working fatty liver
could be the problem Dr Nash and Total
Transformation the sponsors of this next
segment explain
I lost 42 pounds on Dr Nash's program
I'm seven pounds away from my goal if I
can do this I can do anything Becky 42
pounds this is incredible tell us more
about Becky yeah 42 pounds five dress
sizes which is crazy so Becky is a
teacher here in Las Vegas she works for
a private school she happens to um teach
at the same facility that one of my
other clients send their children to so
she happened to see my Private Client
saw the change in weight loss made the
call to me and we were able to get the
same kind of change for her but yeah
she's at her goal weight now five dress
sizes lost it's it's incredible when it
comes to diet and exercise some of us we
have a routine but it's not working
anymore we're not seeing results and
you're saying this could be because of
fatty liver yeah especially after the
pandemic a lot of people are seeing that
what they did in like 2020 is no longer
working nearly as effective now and for
a lot of people this fatty liver could
be the issue especially when you
consider that 45 percent of the kind
country including our children have some
stage of it I know before in the past
you said there's three there's three
ways that fatty liver can prevent you
from losing weight can you describe
those three yeah because most people
think about eating less and moving more
is the main way to lose weight but they
don't know that the liver plays a key
role in your body's ability to burn body
fat so it converts your body fat back
into fuel so you can burn it it also
turns on sixty percent of your thyroid
hormone we all know how thyroid is
important for holding on to a normal
weight and then the third one is the
toxin that one most people are aware of
that the liver controls toxin well if
it's fatty it can't do that and this
toxin now gets stored in your fat style
fat cells and makes the fat stubborn to
lose low diet and exercise correct this
you know what for a lot of people no it
doesn't because most people are purely
focused on the calories in calories out
part of it and again while fatty liver
is reversible the fatty liver isn't
coming because you're fat on the outside
it's coming from damage going on on the
inside so for most people they have to
combine a strategy to go after the liver
to accelerate that fat loss it's an
internal game should a person go see a
doctor to seek treatment before going on
a diet you know I mean maybe before
going on a diet for sure if they have
specific issues but if they're going to
a medical doctor to try to find fatty
liver a lot of times it gets overlooked
one because there is no drug or medical
treatment even if the doctor found it
there's nothing he can do but for most
people you really need Advanced Imaging
to find it you're not going to find it
in a blood test so you might walk away
from that appointment thinking you're
okay when really you're not but there
are classic physical symptoms that we
can look for in that one-on-one
evaluation to help determine if fatty
liver is something you're dealing with
Dr Nash you have the solutions that's
why I love you and you also have a
special every time you come on the show
what do you have for us first I have a
special so normally that online
evaluation is 97 to talk to me and get
these issues corrected but if you want
to find out if you have these issues and
if my program might be the right fit we
have 10 spots available right now for
only 9.97 gets you a chance to talk
one-on-one with me find out what these
issues are that are stopping the weight
loss and let's see if we can get you
some help